greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
from simply learn and today we're going
to talk about digital marketing careers
jobs and resumes so welcome and let's
get started so we live in a world where
everything is digitized whether we're
communicating reading watching
interacting everything is digitized and
one of the benefits of our digitized
world is opportunities and those
opportunities have arisen in the world
of digital marketing so when we mean by
digital marketing we mean advertising to
people via different channels and so
we're gonna hone in on digital marketing
and look at what those opportunities are
so let's talk a little bit about digital
marketing so digital marketing really
involves selling a product or service
using several different online / digital
marketing channels so some of the most
popular digital marketing channels used
by a lot of companies today is SEO which
is search engine optimization SEM which
is search engine marketing that's paid
search so if we see a sponsored ad on
Google that would be related to SEM most
of you're probably already familiar with
the email marketing meaning you've
probably received an email from a
company trying to promote or sell a
product or service so those are some of
the most popular channels of course
there's other channels like video social
affiliate influencer marketing display
so there's a lot of different marketing
channels that fall under the umbrella of
digital marketing and so those are some
of the online marketing channels used by
companies to promote their products and
services and so in a sense that's what
digital marketing is and so because
digital marketing is involves a lot of
channels a lot of companies need people
to you know work on those channels for
that company
moaning that product or services so
let's take a look at some of those
particular roles involved with digital
marketing and the first one really is a
digital marketing manager so that's over
seeing all these different marketing
channels okay so somebody looking and
managing these different marketing
channels we just mentioned like SEO
slash organic search or paid search or
social okay so digital marking managers
overseeing implement these different
campaigns across different channels with
the strategy of either brand awareness
or selling a particular product or
promoting the company's services and so
with the digital marketing manager it's
a broad title in a sense but it comes
with a lot of responsibilities so if we
look at some of these responsibilities
it's really designing and overseeing all
the aspects of digital marketing when we
say all aspects we don't mean just
campaigns but really what we mean is
managing a marketing database if you're
implementing campaigns and you're
collecting information as a result you
want to be able to store and manage that
information appropriately it also comes
down to being able and being familiar
and being fluent in different marketing
channels like jumping from email
marketing to display marketing when you
manage multiple campaigns and channels
you have to have a budget so you got to
be able to develop and maintain a budget
so being a digital marketing manager
means you know being able to articulate
and respond to channels that are working
and assigning budget accordingly based
on performance and not only just
assigning budget but making sure the
budget gets implemented appropriately
social is a big part of digital
marketing and so in itself
that's an 800-pound gorilla meaning it's
a lot of responsibility so plan and
manage social media platforms you know
for a lot of companies they're quick to
jump out there on the deep end when it
comes to social so a digital marketing
manager really is someone who can reel
that in and say you know what look we
don't need to be on Twitter or LinkedIn
you know having that responsibility
taking the responsibility for managing
the social media platforms accordingly
what are the biggest jobs of a digital
marketing manager in my opinion is
maintaining reports and it's not even
maintaining reports I mean a lot of
tools like Google Analytics will create
the report for you we talk about
maintaining reports we really mean
looking at those reports looking at the
performance of these campaigns and
channels and reacting accordingly and
that leads to the next bullet point
really with the digital marketing
manager and that means coming up with
new growth strategies because if let's
just say a paid search campaign is
really performing okay how are we gonna
grow that strategy how are we going to
grow that campaign vice versa if your
Facebook Ads aren't performing what can
we do to get them to grow and perform so
that's the job of a digital marketing
manager react according to the
performance of campaigns and continue to
grow and build out the campaigns and
channels and then with that comes you
know some side projects and some issues
that need to be resolved and so a good
digital marketing manager has their
pulse on everything related to that
particular digital marketing channel for
example a website okay if the website's
getting rebuilt or moving to a new
platform or being redesigned digital
marketing manager needs to be part of
that project and needs to be able to
help manage that project alongside the
channels and campaigns he or she is
responsible for so as you can see a lot
of responsibilities with the digital
marketing manager so with that
responsibility comes experience and so
to jump into the deep end and becoming a
digital marketing manager in my opinion
you need to have some experience maybe
not across all channels but at the very
least some of the most important
channels we talked about already SEO SEM
email social email has been around a
long time
SEO is just so key it's the biggest
marketing
channel out there your paid search is
very fast and dynamic involves a lot of
budget and management so you need
someone with experience and you know
someone with at least five years
experience in digital marketing or
advertising can fit the role of course
there's always gonna be growth this is
digital marketing it's still young if
you compare digital marketing against
traditional platforms like TV or radio
or print we're only talking about 15 to
20 years of experience for digital
marketing out there as an advertising
platform so having five years out of 20
years of existence is not too bad now
with that comes a degree of some sort
with marketing okay so you need to have
at least a bachelor's a masters agree
really goes far because usually those
that contain a master's degree usually
as it have an MBA or Masters of Business
Administration and to me that's a nice
complement to having a nice set of
experience in digital marketing and so
it's also a plus to really have some
knowledge about social media okay some
of the best practices that go with
social media some of the analytics that
go with social media and not just social
media but in general too so what are
some digital marketing best practices
that you with your experience can apply
what's your knowledge of websites do you
have any programming experience do you
have any design experience do you have
any web analytics experience okay having
those skill sets meaning understanding
HTML or CSS or JavaScript or being able
to articulate how a website is
performing in Google Analytics
definitely complement the role of a
digital marketing manager and in most
cases is part of the role of a digital
marketing manager and then one of the
biggest skills required I think every
company looks for this communication and
interpersonal skills so you have to be
able to communicate with your colleagues
with your stakeholders with your clients
with your contractors
anybody else supporting your efforts or
the efforts you're supporting for
somebody else so communication is key
and today's world there's a lot of
communication tools out there I mean you
have traditional email you have text
messaging you have nice tools out there
like a song and slack to help you know
solidify the way communication is
streamlined and so you have to be able
to stay on top of communication because
you're gonna be reporting up and you're
going to be reporting down to you know
those that are part of your efforts and
then a real big big bonus is up to date
with trends and technologies and digital
marketing so stay in the know stay in
the know attend conferences ten webinars
attending this webinar definitely helps
your positioning so stay up to date and
what I usually tell you know other
students of mine is hey you know sign up
for two or three sources out there on
the Internet it could be for example
Google's webmaster blog or Google
Analytics video or YouTube channel or
you know subscribe to website magazine
or you know get an email subscription to
search engine land
there's hundreds of hundreds of
thousands of resources out there on the
Internet there's no excuse not to stay
up to date and then one thing that's not
listed here that I would highly
recommend it's have a blog having a blog
offers up multiple advantages one it
promotes you as a brand okay to whatever
you're blogging about and then in this
case it could be something general like
digital marketing or it could be a
specific channel like SEO or could be
analytically driven meaning you know
numbers and everything related to
digital marketing when it comes to
analytics whatever your niche is you
know write about it because it puts you
in a good position that one you're
up-to-date with the trends again you're
promoting your brand and two it shows
off your communication style so having a
blog whether you keep it updated once a
month twice a month four times a month
goes a long way versus not having a blog
at all
it shows you're enthusiastic about the
industry or in the job profession of
digital marketing and it really puts you
in a good spot so that's my
recommendation there in addition to all
the skills required for this position
and you know salary you know it depends
it depends on experience it depends on
the company I mean if you go with the
nonprofit versus a poor for-profit
company the pay might be lower it
depends on the company you could go with
the startup versus a more traditional
company and if the startup they may pay
more it really depends on the company it
really depends on the industry the
organization the experience that you
have the skill sets you bring to the
table all of that plays and roles so the
salaries listed here are really just
averages really it's averages because if
you look at 73,000
annually in the US okay if you're you
know get a nice digital marketing job
and say Kansas 73,000 is a lot of money
well it's all relevant because if you go
to California in San Francisco 73,000 is
not even the medium salary for somebody
who lives in San Francisco so it is
contingent also on location so what you
need to do when it comes to salary is
take a look at your own experience take
a look at what you've been paid
previously if you have five years
experience and you're making fifty
thousand and you feel you've done a good
job and you've earned the skillsets and
the experience needed for the new
position you're applying for then
there's no reason why you can't ask for
more money than say the average okay so
really a lot of things are contingent on
salary but the one thing you can do to
control salary is make sure your skill
sets are in line with the job required
so let's move on to content strategist
and you know content strategist it's
just a title that we're using for this
webinar I am there's a lot of job titles
out there the key thing here with a
Content strategist is somebody who's
involving themselves with content so the
developing content
okay so you can call it a Content writer
a copywriter a strategist a develop
content developer the king of content
the queen of content it doesn't really
matter what the title is when you see
the word content you know that your job
is to develop content that caters to the
company's objectives and so with a lot
of digital marketing channels out there
today
okay content strategist are in high
demand very high demand so some of the
responsibilities that go with a content
strategist is you want to be able to
manage the editorial calendar to ensure
timely publication and what do I mean by
that well as a Content strategist you
could be asked to write social posts
supporting a social media manager okay
so you want to be able to come up with a
calendar of sorts to be able to post at
a specific point in time that's going to
ensure high engagement so having some
sense of time definitely goes along with
the job okay you want to identify gaps
and content recommend new topics so for
example a blog if you're responsible for
generating content for the company's
blog you probably want to take a look at
the categories and the topics that have
already been written about and you want
to be able to identify new areas of
content that's just an example but you
want to do that across all channels okay
you want to be able to create brand
style guides if a brand doesn't have a
style guide already that's a place where
you can really shine okay because a
brand needs to have a certain tone a
certain message a certain point of view
okay it needs to stand for something and
a good content strategist is one who can
help create it help implement it help
enforce it okay so brand styling goes a
long way with the job okay being able to
not only write perf read and edit pieces
before publishing them goes a long way
to you know some of the best content
strategist I've ever come across are
ones that ask me or colleague to
proofread their own con
okay so you know a good content
strategist is one that looks outward to
make sure that the copy or the content
they're producing is up to snuff it's
aligned with the brand
it's articulate and is centered and
geared towards the intended target
audience so having somebody else
proofread to me says something about a
content strategist and vice versa
being able to proofread somebody else's
work to make sure yes what they're
writing is good solid grammatically
written up the brand and tenant for the
right target audience I mean so that's
part of the job being able to proofread
and editing okay another responsibility
with a Content strategist is identifying
content topics based on keyword research
and this aligns with search okay so with
search engine optimization it's all
about keywords and you need to be able
to identify the content that goes along
with those keywords okay we talked about
this in depth on some of our other SEO
webinars and I'll mention those in a
couple minutes but being able to
identify the content that aligns with
those keywords is really part of an SEO
strategy and to me this next bullet
point really goes a long way you want to
be able to monitor web traffic and
engagement because if you're responsible
for the website if you're responsible
for producing content on a particular
website you want to see how that
contents performing so just because your
content strategist doesn't mean
necessarily you're not immune to looking
at data you are you're everybody has a
role when it comes to the website
everybody should take a look at data and
react accordingly to the data including
those who produce content and then you
want to be able to coordinate with
stakeholders in the organization because
the stakeholders are the one who ones
who are gonna have some say and what
content so just like a digital marketing
manager to me another piece of
responsibility is for the content
strategist to be able to communicate
with the stakeholders let them know hey
this is the content that's going out
this is our editorial calendar hey let
me proofread some of your content hey
this is the brand
style okay so the content strategist
really is somebody who's center in terms
of all content that's developed for a
particular organization now some of the
skills required to me you know you can
have a nice marketing degree or
journalism or literature anything that's
gonna have some background in writing
some experience as a content strategist
or manager or in a similar role so you
could be a blog ambassador for another
brand and fill the role of a Content
strategist you can be an influencer and
be somebody who really influences
different companies and industries that
job would be able to fit a Content
strategist because most influencers
write or produce content so having a
basic understanding of HTML and web
publishing so you want to be able to
understand how the web works you know
you want to be able to stand what it
takes to create a web page because every
web page has content you need to have
experience with SEO and you need to have
experience with keyword research tools
because tamiya content strategist is the
one who drives this part of the SEO
process to me the content strategist
looks at data when it comes to keyword
analysis is able to aptly pick and
choose keywords to align with content
and then write content not just write
content but optimize the content for SEO
and then experience with social media
and not only just social media but the
different platforms out there when I
talk about understanding social media
for business and the different platforms
that can help a business thrive in that
channel you need to understand you know
the tended audiences that go to that
platform you need to understand the
formatting and the opportunities for
writing the content on that platform you
know anybody can you know stroked a
keyboard and put words on a screen or
break out a pen and put words on paper
but it really takes someone with you
know really fine experience to really
know who they're writing for what
platform they're writing
for and the guidelines and the
regulations that go along with writing
that content so to me that separates out
a good content strategist from an
average content strategy and of course
excellent writing and editing skills go
a long way that comes with experience in
my opinion but what you could do if you
lack experience and editing is volunteer
for nonprofit most nonprofits have blogs
volunteer to write a blog post for the
nonprofit or if you don't even want to
go that route like a digital marketing
manager have your own blog if you have a
passion for food or passion for travel
or passion for animals or pets or dogs
write about it that's what's gonna give
you the experience and writing editing
and it shows hey look you're
enthusiastic about something and it
shows your brand and your tone so like a
digital marketing manager how many blog
goes a long way if you don't have your
own blog then be able to gain the
experience necessary in writing and
editing by doing it for others even if
it means pro bono volunteer so salary
just like a digital marketing manager
commencement on a lot of factors
experience location organization you
know the Department of the organization
the type of organization the industry I
mean like I said with the digital
marketing manager position hey if you're
in a start-up you and you're applying
for content strategist role chances are
you're probably gonna ask for more money
than the average because you're probably
going to be writing content not only for
the website of the blog not only for
social but it could be some offline
opportunity as well meaning press
releases brochures TV ad spots radio
spots so you got to be open as a Content
strategist especially when you're
working in a start-up because you're
likely going to wear many hats now if
you're applying for a traditional job at
a company that's been around a long time
then your job may be really focused and
honed in on a
specific you know role so keep that in
mind as well
so these salaries are average so a lot
of factors are involved so let's go into
SEO so an SEO specialist so to be an SEO
Punda an SEO expert somebody who's
really familiar with the role and the
channel of SEO so to me SEO is a big
channel a lot of responsibility
so SEO specialist or responsible for
analyzing reviewing implementing not
just change to the website but things
that happen off the website because with
SEO SEO is built into two branches or
two strategies off page and on page okay
so being an SEO specialist you got to be
able to hone in on what to do on your
own website for on-page SEO but you got
to be able to be savvy enough to put
together an off page strategy and not
only that you got to be technically
savvy because a lot of what goes in SEO
and false and technical aspects like for
for page load or sitemaps or CSS or you
know accelerated mobile pages mobile
usability structured snippets featured
snippets all of these are factors that
are related to SEO so an SEO specialist
is somebody who really is able to juggle
both the website from a technical
standpoint on page optimization and off
page optimization it's a big role and so
therefore if we break down the
responsibilities again it's reviewing
and analyzing the site for improvement
and optimization in other words somebody
needs to be savvy enough if they're
called an SEO specialist to be able to
conduct an audit for an SEO strategy and
be able to identify areas of improvement
so preparing strategy reports so what
does that mean well that can mean a lot
of things so when we talk about strategy
and reports you need to be savvy enough
to create a keyword analysis okay you
need to be savvy enough to be able to
assign keywords you need to be savvy
enough to even know how to optimize a
page
yes you may have a Content strategist do
that work but as an SEO specialist you
need to be able to know how to do that
as well okay you need to be able to
identify keywords okay in a keyword
analysis just like a Content strategist
you need to be able to assign keywords
and you need to be able to write
effective SEO content not only for the
blog or website and social media but it
could be across other different channels
as well so being part of the content is
part of being an SEO specialist because
if you work at a start-up you may not
have a quote unquote content strategist
to support you so you may have to do
everything you may have to and you're
not only odd at the site you may not
only have to address some of the website
needs from a technical standpoint but
you may have to do the keyword analysis
the keyword assignments and optimize the
content for SEO and then take it to off
page you may have to write the content
for off page SEO meaning social or it
could be on other platforms like
Wikipedia medium Reddit Cora okay so all
of these platforms require content that
are part of an SEO strategy so being
able to you know prepare strategy being
able to identify keywords via keyword
analysis being able to write content
that support your SEO strategy or all
part of responsibilities of an SEO
specialist and again part of that
strategy because it's on-page and
off-page is you need to be able to put
together an off page SEO strategy and
that's going to again involve content so
before you start writing content for
various platforms
you need to be able to put in a sound
strategy what platforms are we going to
go after you know what are the domain
and page authority of those platforms
how much content do we need to write how
often the frequency what type of content
are we going to write all of that's part
of a link building off page SEO strategy
and to me one of the biggest
responsibilities of an SEO specialist is
being able to not only analyze keyword
it's an SEO techniques used by your
competitors but just being able to
analyze and measure SEO overall yes you
need to be able to look at what your
competitors are doing but you need to be
able to for example leverage an SEO
platform look at that SEO platform
understand how your overall SEO efforts
are performing and continue to make
adjustments so that's an SEO specialist
wrapped up and if we look at some of the
skills you know you need to have some
SEO experience not having SEO experience
and applying for an SEO job
is really selling yourself short because
SEO involves some technical aspects some
creative aspects and some good sound
strategy along with a lot of analytics
so you need to be familiar with
analytics tools and other tools that are
going to measure the performance of your
SEO strategy so you need to be able to
familiarize yourself with some of the
SEO platforms that are out there like
mods or SEM rush because they produce
analytic data as well meaning ranking
information or domain and page Authority
you need to be able to understand what
those metrics are and how to react to
them you need to be able to understand
Google Analytics from an organic search
perspective you know what are some of
the KPIs you're aligning with organic
search how you measuring organic search
behavior from an engagement standpoint
or from a conversion standpoint and
because SEO has a technical aspect to it
you need to be able to understand you
know the web platform that you're on is
it WordPress okay how do plugins work do
I have all my plugins what theme am I
using you know what's the CSS of that
theme so you need to be able to
understand all the elements of your
website that are going to affect SEO and
so with that you need to stay in the
know you need to understand all the
different ranking factors and how these
different search engines run in terms of
their algorithms you know the pundits
say they're 200 plus different factors
that affect Google's ranking algorithm
so what are those 200 ranking factor
do you have a certain knowledge set of
how search works okay do you know how
the bots work okay do you know the best
practice of foresight map okay so these
are all the things you need to know and
all the skills you need to obtain to be
an SEO specialist and just like every
position we're gonna cover and we've
covered already you need to stay up to
date with the latest trends and
practices because SEO changes frequently
Google changes their algorithms and they
change their algorithms without even
letting you know so you need to stay
up-to-date with what Google is doing
okay or some of the other search engines
and so there's a lot of different
resources available you need to be savvy
enough to pick and choose the resources
that are gonna keep you up to date you
need to know you know how search console
works I mean there's just a lot of
different factors involved with SEO it's
a very well-rounded channel with a lot
of responsibilities so you know if you
don't have the experience necessary well
in my opinion you can come in easily as
a content strategist you can't come in
as a web developer and be an SEO
specialist because you're gonna have
some working knowledge of you know how
website works or how social or off page
SEO works but an SEO specialist is one
who puts it all together and so to me
you know salary again these are just
averages and they do vary okay whether
in India USA Europe other parts of Asia
South America
you know salary is going to be
contingent on location it's going to be
contingent on your experience and the
one thing here to prove your experience
and to prove your worth in terms of
salary is to be able to show what you've
done in the past in terms of progress
for another client or another website so
you need to be able to be able to show
you know those who are you're looking to
work for here's what I've done in the
past here's the methodology here the
metrics I used to measure
here are some of the results of that
effort okay so you need to be able to
show you know some case studies best
practices and historical performance and
to me if you could show that then you're
worth every bit of the salary that that
particular company would offer up so
let's move on to SEM specialist so SEO
specialist a lot of factors involved
there off page on page SEO is search but
it's a whole different set of skills
versus SEO a whole different skill set
and why because an SEM specialist it
could be an SEM manager or whatever
again you want to call it but the
channel here is SEM search engine
marketing and and really somebody who's
part of SEM is going to be able to
manage paid search campaigns across
multiple channels across multiple
networks
okay so may not even be just a search
Network it could be the Display Network
okay so you need to know how Google and
Yahoo and Bing and buy it when LinkedIn
and Twitter all these paid search
platforms you need to know how they work
and be able to manage campaigns
effectively on those platforms so some
of the some of the responsibilities now
I will say this for the Ness with SEM
it's very fast-paced so you need your
responsibilities to keep up with
campaign performance and some of the
things you're going to do some of the
responsibilities you're going to conduct
YB by managing campaigns are gonna be
testing a lot of testing and a lot of
analyzing data okay so you need to be
able to react to the data you see okay
so you need to identify trends to
achieve maximum return on investment so
in my opinion a good SEO specialist is
one who identifies their KPIs beforehand
and then identifies the strategy
beforehand and then being able to
execute that strategy and then after
executing that strategy being able to
optimize the
Payne so you're able to achieve maximum
performance and maximum results that's
really the job of an SCM specialist so
you need to be able to execute according
to strategy you need to be able to track
and report on the performance and not
just track and report but you need to be
able to react because with pay per click
or cost per click or sponsored search or
search engine marketing whatever you
want to call it it's going to be fast
paced meaning you're gonna get data and
you're gonna get data very quickly and
so you have to be good at looking at
numbers and reacting to those numbers
and another responsibility is being able
to manage a budget if a client gives you
money you need be able to manage that
budget accordingly first things first
you need to be able to plot a strategy
that's gonna spend that budget wisely
and you need to be able to monitor and
maintain that budget so you don't over
spend the budget and not only just over
spend the budget but on your spend the
budget so if a client hands you a
thousand dollars
don't spend 500 of it don't spend 1,500
of it spend a thousand look at the
results along the way and come back to
the client tell them hey here's the
maximum results for that thousand
dollars and here's what I recommend
moving forward based on the work and the
optimization we've done that's part of
being an SEM specialist is being able to
manage and maintain the budget maximize
your efforts for those paid search
campaigns why you're spending that
budget and some of the other
responsibilities with an SEM specialist
is not just managing numbers and data
it's being able to write ad copy and not
only write a copy but know the different
guidelines and formats of these
different paid campaigns and platforms
because the guidelines for Google are
going to be different from the
guidelines on Facebook and so you need
to be able to also react to that ad copy
according to the platform and not only
the ad copy but the landing pages as
well you need to be able and be savvy
and technically savvy enough to be able
to
unique landing pages for your
pay-per-click campaigns okay that's part
of an SCM specialist leading the way on
creating landing pages and not just
creating landing pages but also doing
a/b testing on those landing pages a
good as the in specialist with
experience is going to be able to raise
their hand and say look this landing
page is not performing let's put an a/b
test in place so that we can improve
performance over paid search campaign so
one of the ultimate jobs of an SEM
specialist is always always looking at
keywords being able to identify keywords
that are performing you know being savvy
enough to pause the keywords that are
not performing being able to optimize
keywords to gain better performance and
to expand the keyword list whether that
be in a different campaign or ad group
or you know ad set so identifying and
managing keywords is probably the
number-one job of an SCM specialist
because keywords are what drive a lot of
paid search especially on Google Yahoo
and Bing so a lot of responsible within
SEM specialists you're giving the
responsibility of running a campaign
against a budget and you have to move at
a fast pace so it's not an easy role
it's not for the faint at heart you need
to be able to react to data at a very
fast pace and so what are some of the
skills required for a job like this well
you need to have experience with search
engine marketing in general but it would
help to have experience across multiple
platforms I would even go as far as not
just saying Yahoo and Bing in Google but
Facebook LinkedIn Admiral and not only
just Google search but you need to be
able to show that you can manage paid
search campaigns across Google's Display
Network meaning display banners and even
video campaigns on YouTube or
remarketing campaigns or shopping ad
campaigns so you need to have a well
rounded
view and well-rounded experience on how
search works and all the different types
of campaigns you can run on a search
platform you need to be well versed in
metrics paid search is about reacting to
data and performing the campaign at the
maximum so if you're managing a campaign
for an e-commerce website what are your
KPIs what's your cost per acquisition
you know if I'm selling a t-shirt for
$20 do I want my cost per acquisition to
be $25 no so you need to be able to
understand the different metrics and
different KPIs aligned with a specific
strategy or website or business and you
need to manage against those metrics
whether that be cost per acquisition or
conversion rate or raw conversions you
need to be staying up to date with the
latest SEM trends because paid search
especially on Google they come out with
a lot of features and updates all the
time and you need to be able to know
what those updates are so you could take
advantage of them do you know that you
know Google offers up responsive ads
okay do you know that they have
different ad extensions for say mobile
or location okay you need to stay up to
date with all the features on every
platform so you can maximize those
features for your clients again you need
to have strong analytical skills you
know if you're not good with numbers
then being an SCM specialist is probably
not for you being comfortable numbers
and being able to react to those numbers
that's a sign of a good strong
analytical skill set now SEM involves a
lot of testing because a/b testing and
pay-per-click go together because paper
clicks a controlled environment so doing
a/b testing and being able to identify a
beat se not just for landing pages but
for ad copy so you need to be able to be
familiar with how a B testing works and
being comfortable you know identifying
areas that need a/b testing crumbing up
with variations coming up with those
KPIs and then having a well rounded
knowledge
how old website works never hurts
because you may be tasked with setting
up the a/b test for landing page so to
me you know being an SCM specialist it's
a cool cool job I particularly like
pay-per-click it's very fast-paced you
get to react you get to do a lot of
different things here across different
platforms and to see the fruits of your
labor pay off for the client meaning
good campaign performance is well worth
the reward
of being an SEO specialist and again you
know we're looking at 65,000
in the US and that's contingent on
experience and to me I would probably go
as far as saying you know you need to
have at least five years experience as
an SCM specialist and you need to be
able to show a well-rounded view of what
you've managed in the past so whether
that be paid search campaigns on Google
search display video shopping
remarketing you know social paid ads on
different platforms like LinkedIn
Twitter Facebook you know you can even
do paid search on other platforms or
websites as well and even understanding
you know how Adsense works you know the
other way around how a publisher gets
money because that's part of the Display
Network so looking at if not from an
advertiser point of view but from a
publisher standpoint so showing a
well-rounded knowledge of how paid
search works really goes a long way into
how much you actually make as an SEM
specialist let's move over to social
media marketer so social media social
media marketers are in high demand
because a lot of companies are on social
media so social media marketers achieve
custom engagement intimacy they want to
drive website traffic they want to
convert that traffic to revenue okay so
they want to take advantage of all the
features available on that particular
social media platform and so some of the
responsibilities involved with being a
social media marketer and
you know building and executing a
strategy on that particular social media
Stratfor m-- so you want to be able to
look at what your competitors are doing
you want to put in a good strategy and
when I say good strategy that means
identifying what platforms identifying
the messaging okay is it going to be
brand or SEO based or sales based okay
being able to build an audience on that
platform knowing who your target
audience is
okay that's first and foremost from a
social media perspective a good social
media marketer needs to know what
they're getting themselves involved with
before they execute okay and then once
you are able to plan and strategize
then comes the work you need to be able
to generate edit publish and share
content and the whole point here is it's
based on strategy so as a brand
awareness is a community building at the
end of the day you're gonna want to see
some type of engagement or you're gonna
want to be able to see something in
return for the content you're posting so
are you in for likes or are you in for
shares or are you in for website traffic
or are you in for conversions okay so
you need to be able to manage that based
on the content you publish and so to me
when you're talking about content and
you're talking about social media you
need to be able to lean on a good social
media platform there plenty out there
like buffer or or sprout social or
HootSuite or later there are plenty of
social media platforms out there and you
need to familiarize yourself and be able
to leverage that social media platform
to manage your content manage the data
you're seeing from the social media
platforms and then basically the whole
idea behind social is it's based on a
strategy so you need to be able to
improve that strategy by analyzing those
metrics insights and understand some of
the best practices in order to improve
so it's a very broad sense of
responsibilities because it does depend
on the platform it does depend on the
business it does depend on your strategy
you could just be responsible for
Twitter
okay so Twitter has you know very
limited number of characters involved
with content but just because there's
not a lot of content doesn't mean the
strategy isn't as intense as it would be
on Facebook or LinkedIn so you need to
be able to adjust and adapt to the
platform you're working on and so to me
some of the skills required you know it
helps have an MBA but I think it
definitely does help to have experience
as a social media marketer you know two
years is probably good enough experience
but in my opinion the more experience
you have and the more experience you
have across multitude of platforms
definitely says something about your
skill set
so it needs a crossover as well it needs
to crossover that skill set needs a
crossover in a different marketing
channels for example paid search why
because you could be asked to write
content for paid ads on Facebook and
needs to be able to cross over an SEO
why because you could be asked to write
content for off page SEO on a particular
social media platform it means it could
be able to cross over and say email
because you could be contributing to
that email newsletter that goes out
that's pulling snippets of content from
your social work so you need to
familiarize yourself with how different
marketing channels work because they
overlap with social media and then just
like a Content strategist just like SEO
SEM a digital marketing manager you need
to be able to and be comfortable going
into google analytics or your analytics
platform you need to be able to identify
social as a channel and be able to
measure how that particular channel is
working and not only how its working in
terms of your KPIs which could be
engagement or conversion based but you
need to be savvy enough to react to the
data let's just say you're not driving
enough traffic from Facebook and
Facebook is your primary social media
platform what are you going to do how
are you going to adjust that strategy to
drive more traffic so that's a
it's savvy social media marketer
somebody who's able to go into an
analytics platform and react to the data
they're seen based on the strategy that
they're trying to implement and then you
know having well-rounded experience with
all the different social networking and
social analytics tools definitely shows
your experience if you have one
experience a little experience with just
one platform like sprout social
then get experience jump into HootSuite
or buffer or some of these other
platforms and know the differences
between them because basically one
social media platform may not work for
one company you may have to lean on one
or two based on the features that they
offer and you need to be savvy enough to
identify that so that you can assist the
organization you're working for so that
to me shows a lot of maturity and
experience knowing where to go to
maximize your efforts so social media
marketers they're in abundance but
they're in need okay so you can really
niche yourself a good career whether
that be at a startup or whether it be in
a traditional company whether it be in a
non-profit or for-profit whether that be
in tech or real estate or law or medical
or insurance it doesn't matter social
media marketers are in need but a good
social media marketer are those that
take into account the skills we talked
about let's turn our attention to email
marketing so let's take a look at email
marketing here so email marketing has
been around a long time
so email marketing specialist if you
will are those that promote the
organization organizations product or
services via email so the aim is to
really get those emails to work so email
marketing has been around most people
today have email addresses are familiar
with email marketing because most
organizations use email marketing as a
digital marketing channel and so good
email marketing specialist is
responsible for the design and the
implementation
an email marketing campaign and so to me
they need to be able to also identify
the platform out they're going to be
working with so if you're going to
implement an email marketing campaign
you need to be able to identify the
platform that you're going to work in
and there are plenty of email marketing
platforms and there are plenty of
marketing automation tools that offer up
email as a feature so you need to be
able to identify not only a marketing
automation platform that works with your
email marketing strategy but a good
email marketing platform you know
there's vertical response there's
MailChimp there's you know a lot of
different marketing clout my email
marketing platforms out there so try and
test a few of them and understand how
they work just like social media there's
an abundance of email marketing
platforms so you need to be able to
identify one that's going to align with
the strategy give you all the features
and benefits available and you need to
be able to identify your target audience
because you're not going to send one
email to your entire audience list
you're gonna need to be able to dissect
that entire audience listen to different
segments and that's what a good email
marketing specialist does identify
different segments of audience you need
to be just like a Content strategist
able to proofread copy in some cases you
may be writing that copy for the email
if you work at a start-up and you don't
have a content strategist maybe you are
content strategist who is also assigned
as an email marketing specialist either
way you need to be able to look at the
copy that's in that email and ask
yourself you know is this copy and
Tenant for target audience does it fit
our brand guidelines does it fit our
brand messaging do the call to actions
fit what we're trying to achieve you
know all that's part of an email
marketing specialist I'm an email
marketing specialist is a good set of
eyes
and you need to understand the technical
aspects of email because know
longer are we sending email to somebody
on a computer on a desktop who's
downloading that email on to say some
software program like Outlook not today
today most people are looking at email
on the fly on-the-go via mobile so we
need to make sure that emails you know
fit our audience across multiple devices
so you need to be able to ensure that
you know your emails are mobile friendly
because most people are looking at
emails on their mobile phones and timing
is everything with email metrics just
like any other channel is important with
email so you need to know when you're
gonna be able to send that email what
time of day you're gonna be able to send
that email and you need to understand
the campaign performance why so that you
can respond and optimize the email
marketing efforts moving forward and
then another responsibility not really
listed here what it does go with the job
and that's a be testing so just like an
SCM specialist you need to be able to
understand how a be testing works why
because you may not just be optimizing
landing pages for an a/b test you may be
looking at an a/b test for subject lines
in fact a good email marketing
specialist never sends out an email
without a be testing the subject line
and so you need to be familiar with how
a be testing works because that goes
along with improving campaign
performance and knowing industry
policies and best practices especially
with email goes a long way because there
are a lot of regulations involved around
you know email and it does come down to
also the industry what you could say and
what you can't say by industry does
factor in so staying up-to-date with
industry policies and best practices
definitely is part of the responsibility
of an email marketing specialist now
skills required should have experience
with email marketing and to me I would
take this a step for
they're you know having well-rounded
experience working for a start-up
working for a larger company and working
for a company that has different target
audiences meaning segmented audiences as
you can show that hey I know how to send
out an email to a large number of people
and they could be subsets of a bigger
audience and you need to be able to show
you know the different styles and the
different platforms for email marketing
that you've worked with and a lot of
email requires HTML or knowledge of HTML
so you're gonna have to know HTML
because you may have to edit HTML you
need to know how UTM tracking works okay
urgent tracking modules so if you don't
know what UTM tracking is and you want
to be an email marketing specialist you
need to know what that is and get some
hands-on experience using UTM tracking
because your need to track emails and if
you're using Google Analytics as your
analytics platform then you definitely
will need UTM tracking because your need
to be able to be comfortable to go into
Google Analytics and look at your email
campaign performance does it align with
your KPIs and you need to be able to
have some project management skills
because a lot goes into email marketing
you know it's the design of it it's the
timing of it it's the copy
it's the a/b testing it's the analytical
part if you're working for a big company
that has 35 different target audiences
you could be sending up multiple emails
on a daily basis for different audiences
and so you need to be able to project
manage each of these email campaigns and
so those are the skills required for an
email marketing specialist and again
salary contingent upon experience the
more experience you have as an email
marketer the more you're gonna make and
experience to me is based on you know
how many email marketing platforms you
work with how many companies have you
done email marketing for how
well-rounded have your emails been how
many target audience is how big have
this target audience has been do you
understand the concept of analytic
and the concept of a/b testing so if you
do and you checked off all these boxes
then you can command more than what the
average is for an email marketing
specialist so let's take a look at a
digital marketing resume so my
recommendation and this is just my
opinion would be to build your resume
off a platform like LinkedIn so if
you're not on LinkedIn then I would
definitely recommend you get on LinkedIn
and if you're gonna be a social media
marketer then you definitely should be
on LinkedIn you're gonna be a content
strategy or even digital marketing
manager you need to be on LinkedIn
LinkedIn is a business of business
platform so it allows you to put your
best foot forward in front of a lot of
people so not only those you connect
with but there's a lot of recruiters who
work on LinkedIn and these recruiters
are looking for people with experience
who fit the job they're trying to fill
and so to me and we look at a good
resume you know especially on LinkedIn
LinkedIn allows you to have a platform
to put in all your experience and so you
know depending on what you're trying to
go for
I would niche towards that so if you're
going to be a digital marketing manager
then you could see in this example two
years experience with content SEO
marketing automation email SEM and
market research those are part of the
skill sets required for a digital
marketing manager so you want to put in
a summary a good summary to include how
much experience you have and anything
that supports your claim to be a digital
marketing manager or an email marketing
manager or social media marketing
manager that's part of the summary and
then you want to put your experience in
there and to me putting your experience
in there is key I would include all your
experience everything you've ever done
geared towards the job you're going for
and to me one thing about experience is
when you write out your experience put
in what your responsibilities were and
then
I think what's key here in this example
you could see this person had associate
digital marketing manager experience for
one year and what they did was they
actually showed the improvements they
made as a digital marketing manager so
you can see increased organic page use
30% with the reduction of bounce rates
on websites through site content
management and SEM analysis so they
actually put some quantitative data in
there to show that hey this is what I've
done and this is what I've done to
improve this particular company's
website and so to me it's
action-oriented
it shows some quantitative analysis it
shows you've actually done work that
made improvement and it also shows that
you have command of analytics because
every job under the digital marketing
realm involves quantitative and
analytical data and so putting
analytical data and your resume shows
that you know what you're talking about
so here you can see on the next example
hey as a marketing intern for Nike you
know one good year here's all the tools
i've worked with so to me that's also a
plus you want to show again a lot of
these positions require knowledge of
some of the most common platforms okay
whether that an analytical platform an
email marketing platform and SEO
platform or social media platform if you
worked in that platform put it down it
shows that you're well rounded and so
that's a good suggestion to show hey you
have experience working with these
platforms and hey you have command of
analytics obviously putting your
education down there you know to me I'm
not a recruiter I don't think cpa such a
big deal to me
experience is more of a big deal and
then you definitely to support that
experience to show that you're in the
know this show that you stay up-to-date
that show that you're up-to-date with
the latest trends and best practices I
would definitely put your certifications
and so if you're trying to be in as
gM specialist or strategist and make
sure you have Google Ads
certifications and not just Google ads
but all facets of Google ads and what
Google Ads has to offer get your
certification in mobile get your
certification and video get it in
shopping get it in display put their
certifications down there because it
shows you're well-rounded and regardless
of what position you're going for
whether the big content or email go for
the Google Analytics certification all
these certifications I mentioned by
Google are free Bing has certifications
Facebook has certifications get those
certifications and put them down there
because again it shows that you're in
command of your career it shows that
you're up to date with the latest and
greatest it shows that you know what
you're talking about
because you've taken the initiative to
get a certification so to me these are
all the key ingredients to a good resume
you know niche it to what you're trying
to do right a good summary that supports
your effort you put your experience down
there but when you put your experience
support it with quantitative
measurements and metrics put down all
the experience you have with platforms
you know put some other elements in
there that are intangibles like
communication you know show that you
know how to communicate
hey we slack to communicate to a team of
100 across five different countries as
an example because it shows that you
have a grasp of what it takes to
communicate with a team at large of
course put your education but more
importantly get those certifications put
them down there because it shows you
know what you're doing you're walking
the walk and not just talking the talk
so if you're interested in a career in
digital marketing and you don't have the
necessary experience and say google
analytics then take a look at our Google
Analytics tutorial for beginners you
know looking over the webinar give you
some more insight into Google Analytics
and propel you into maybe taking the
certification likewise we have one for
email marketing if you
interesting to being an email marketer
you know take a look at our webinar on
email marketing and then SEO if you
don't have the necessary experience and
you're not sure of everything involved
in SEO then take a look at SEO of
tutorial for beginners so we have a lot
more webinars available at simply learn
so if you're lacking in one area the
other you know go to our channel on
YouTube to fill in the gaps of what you
need to enhance your career so I want to
thank you for attending today's webinar
about digital marketing careers jobs and
resumes if you need any more information
again go to our YouTube channel with
simply learn or you can go to simply
learn comm for more information thank
you again and I look forward to seeing
you on future webinars hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simply
learn youtube channel and click here to
watch similar videos to nerd up and get
certified
click here